c'est un reportage exceptionnel que l'on
vous propose maintenant direction le
niger dans le sahara un pays extrêmement
pauvre malgré tout coupé en deux avec le
sud relativement développé le nord aride
et miséreux c'est pourtant au nord que
sont exploités les très lucratives mines
d'uranium où les touareg affirme être
exclu de ce profil ont pris les armes
face au pouvoir central c'est le dossier
de la rédaction
il est signé olivier pon sèche le nord
du niger est le théâtre d'une guerre
oubliée à peine étouffé par les dunes du
ténéré à part cette compagnie rebelles
qui s'entraîne l'endroit n'a jamais été
aussi désert les civils ont fui quand
l'armée nigérienne venus du sud du pays
a pris ses quartiers dans cette ancienne
école
leur mission traquer ces rebelles
touareg qui s'était alors replié dans
les montagnes seules hamida famille sont
restés
la vie est dure depuis les dernières
sécheresse pas grand chose à manger
à part le traditionnel pain de sable
mais ils ont eu la vie sauve
l'armée s'est contenté de brûlé leurs
maisons quand elle a exécuté trois de
leurs voisins des vieillards
du coup ramid a pris les armes et à son
tour il a rejoint la rébellion il ya des
larmes mais qui avait ni priait les
jeunes est massacrée et des chamois et
ça c'est laid
les atteintes fruits les intérêts sont
noirs le niger a un des taux de
mortalité infantile les plus élevés au
monde
des versets du coran attaché à son
poignet en guise de mulets tu l'avenir
du petit dernier est incertain quant à
l'orientation scolaire de ses grandes
soeurs la question ne se pose pas
ou plutôt elle ne se pose plus les
d'habitude tu vas à l'école quelle
classe cp maintenant l'école a été cassé
voici ce qu'il reste de son école
construite par une ong canadienne il ya
deux ans l'armée s'y étaient installés
chassant les enfants il y a quelques
mois les rebelles l'ont reprise les
armes à la main
bilan 15 soldats tués le reste a été
fait prisonnier matériel armes et
véhicules sont désormais aux mains des
maquisards une cuisante défaite pour le
gouvernement pour avoir décrit cette
réalité des journalistes croupissent
encore dans les prisons nigérienne des
graffitis leur sont dédiés aux milieux
d'inscription pro mnj le mouvement
nigérien pour la justice c'est le nom
officiel de cette rébellion
ils seraient plus de 2000 touareg mais
aussi tous bouts ou djerma à avoir
rejoint le chef rebelle a rally à
longueau la première des choses c'est
les terrains l'intérêt ou le mail au
combat ses intérêts et que les sols de
tout ce n'est ni sa principale
revendication touche le groupe français
areva dont les mines d'uranium se trouve
sur les terres des touaregs qui n'en
profitent pas ni en termes d'embauché
mis en terme d'équipement le niger est
le troisième producteur mondial
d'uranium
mais malgré cette manne pas même un seul
fouine a été creusée ici selon les
populations locales
tout l'argent irait au sud plus
développée et sous le contrôle du
gouvernement
mais au jeu des joueurs qu'on a pris par
l'équipe
une balle maintenant les ennemis mais
ces six là qu'est ce qu'ils veulent une
région autonome et un meilleur partage
des richesses
mais le président mamadou tandja élu
depuis 99 ne les a jamais prises au
sérieux
à la radio il les qualifie même de
trafiquants de drogue et les accuse de
torturer leurs prisonniers
alors nous demandons à rencontrer ces
hommes détenus dans les montagnes on
nous y emmène nous les verrons à la nuit
tombée par respect pour la convention de
genève sur les prisonniers de guerre
vous ne verrez pas les visages de ces
huit soldats gouvernementaux
vous pouvez vous reposer manger ce
combien de temps que vous êtes
prisonnier 2007
le commandant arrive et m'interrompt
l'heure de la prière
drôle de scène que ses geôliers et ses
prisonniers qui se disent tous nigériens
et qui prient ensemble le même dieu
d'ailleurs peu après notre départ
certains ont été libérés sans
contrepartie
car le pouvoir refuse toujours de
négocier